hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his homily number 16 on the gospel of
Matthew John chrysostom is going to
first discuss these three precepts that
are given about anger one after another
and then he's going to tell his readers
and listeners
neither does he meaning Christ stop at
those precepts only which have been
mentioned but adds also others more than
these whereby he signifies how much
account he makes thereof so after having
been threatened by the council the
judgment and hell he added other sayings
again in harmony with the former saying
and so here's the first and the main one
that he discusses if you bring your gift
to The Altar and there remember your
brother has anything against you leave
your gift before the Altar and go away
okay first be reconciled to your brother
and then come back and offer your gift
so it's saying interrupt your religious
duties your religious service whatever
it is that you've committed yourself to
and prioritize instead reconciliation
with and it doesn't have to be your
brother it could be your sister it could
be whoever it is that has something
against you or perhaps that you have
against them so the the
injunction here the imperative is to
prioritize reconciliation
and Chris's thumb says oh goodness o
exceeding love to human beings he Christ
God makes no account of the honor do
himself right so what is he what is he
Christ prioritizing
um the reconciliation that is going to
be taking place he says
um
for the sake of our he makes no account
of the honor due to himself for the sake
of our love towards our neighbor
implying that not all from any enmity
nor out of any desire to punish had he
uttered these former threatenings but
out of very tender affection what can be
milder than these things let my service
be interrupted that your love may
continue since this is also a sacrifice
and here we might pause for a minute so
if you've got a beef with somebody it's
already a sacrifice to follow this
imperative to live according to this
Rule and to try to see if you can work
out some kind of reconciliation now it
it doesn't say that the reconciliation
attempt is automatically going to be
successful or anything like that it just
tells you this is what you're supposed
to do so the service is supposed to be
interrupted
reconciliation is supposed to be
attempted at least
and he says um
for this cause he said not after the
offering or before the offering but
while the very gift lies there while the
sacrifice is already beginning he sends
you out of it to be reconciled to your
brother and neither after removing that
which lies before us nor before
presenting the gift but while it is in
the midst he tells you to go do that and
then Christmas some says well why what
is the motivation here what is the point
what is the purpose what is the end and
he says that there's two reasons uh one
of them is that his will is to point out
that he highly values charity right uh
or in the Greek I got paid love this is
the thing that should be focused upon
and that's why you should be reconciling
rather than just bringing whatever
sacrifice you have whatever service
you're supposed to be
engaged in uh and then he says there's a
second
point to this he's imposing a necessity
of reconciliation and he says such a
necessity of reconciliation as admits of
no excuse whoever's been charged not to
offer before he be reconciled will
hasten if not for love of his neighbor
which is what you ought to have but so
that the gift won't lie unconsecrated to
run onto them who's been grieved and do
away with the enmity or hatred the lack
or the opposition to charity or love
right so those are the motives for this
that chrysostom is discerning
and he uh he's got some really
interesting
um speculations here he says
who is this actually being directed to
is it the person who's the wrongdoer
who's being sent to be reconciled with
the person who they have done wrong to
who is suffering because of that or is
he talking to the sufferer the one who
wrong has been done too and saying go
and be reconciled with the person who
did you wrong he says well we could
actually look at it both of these ways
he says in this place he's sending the
wrong doer to the sufferer in his prayer
he leads the sufferer to the wrongdoer
and reconciles them what what prayer is
he talking about well the uh our father
right forgive people their debts so here
if he has something against you go the
way on to him and then he says rather
even here too he seems to me to be
sending the injured person and for some
reason he said not reconcile
thyself to your brother but be thou
reconciled and while the saying seems to
pertain to the aggressor the whole of it
really pertains to him that is aggrieved
and so you know which is it it could be
either you could put it into
contemporary parlance saying if you got
a beef if you've got a conflict if
there's something between you and
another person and maybe it has to do
with somebody who's close to you
somebody who you should in fact already
be reconciled with okay stop what you're
doing you know if you're in the choir
stop singing if you're about to put
something into the collection plate that
hold on if you're bringing up you know
in in a church the bread and the wine
for consecration whoop hold on there
buddy you need to go and fix what has
been damaged what has gone wrong whether
you are the wrongdoer or the sufferer or
maybe a little bit of both right because
maybe it's an ongoing sort of thing he
points out another very interesting
facet to this as well he says and Christ
said not when you have suffered any of
the greater wrongs then be reconciled
but there would be some trifle that he
has against you so it could be a big
thing it could be a small thing we're
not supposed to say oh you know only the
big things matter let the Small Things
slide I'll get maybe we'll you know have
10 of those and go reconcile about that
after you add them up no it's just any
sort of thing that you have against
somebody else he also says
uh whether justly or unjustly he doesn't
you know worry about that merely if your
brother has something against you
and he says though it be justly not even
in that case should you protract the
enmity the hatred even if you have
something just against them you're not
supposed to just hold on to it and hold
it over them and refuse to you know be
reconciled or forgive and so you know
this is a very interesting uh you know
set of of
non-qualifications you might say that he
is bringing about and he tells us you
know going back to the injunction about
don't call your brother a fool otherwise
you'll be liable to Hellfire he says
um to forbid our calling fool is a
preventative of enmity a preventative of
hatred right but what if you already do
hate them what if you already lack love
he says to command reconciliation is a
means of removing the diseases that take
root in us that arise because of that
enmity and hatred and he says Mark how
both commands are set forth with
earnestness in the former case he
threatened hell here he receives not the
gift before the reconciliation
indicating displeasure God doesn't want
the gift that we would otherwise bring
so long as we're not reconciled with our
our brother or you know close family
members or neighbors or pick whatever
you you would like there
so this is a very important uh facet of
it he also does talk about another uh
verse that follows agree with your
adversary quickly while you're in the
way with them you know urging a sort of
sense of time don't let it go to a law
court because then you're actually going
to pay right fix these things right away
so there's a timeliness you could say
that is connected with us and of course
he's going to bring up you know Paul's
injunction before the sun sets do away
with the anger or the hatred and then he
says well this is very much like before
the offering is completed
be reconciled or quickly while you're in
the way with the person before you come
to the doors of the Law Court figure out
how you're going to come to agreements
and so these are all you could say other
injunctions that are showing according
to John chrysostom how we ought to
behave in relation to those with whom
we've found ourselves in some sort of
conflict
and he concludes near the end let us be
obedient to his sayings let us not
oppose ourselves nor be contentious for
first of all even antecedently to the
rewards these injunctions have their
pleasure and profit in themselves and if
to the most part they seem to be
burdensome and the trouble which they
cause great have it in your mind that
you're doing it for Christ's sake and
the pain will be pleasant so you know we
can look at this as this is the way to
really offer something to Christ namely
the love that we should be feeling in
relation to other people our neighbors
or in this case our our brothers and
sisters right so reconciliation is
really something Central and it is
supposed to be there in place of hatred
or anger